The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
BOGDAN FEDELES: Greetings,
and welcome to 5.07
Biochemistry online.
I'm Dr. Bogdan Fedeles.
Let's metabolize some problems.
Today we're going to be talking
about problem one of problem
set seven.
Now this is a problem
we are chasing labels
through biochemical pathways.
Although it sounds
funny, it's actually
one of the established
ways through which we
can test whether the mechanism
we propose for these pathways
is in fact consistent with what
we observe inside the cells.
In part a of this
problem, we're going
to be looking at glycogen,
and try to figure out
which carbon's in
glycogen end up being
lost as CO2 in the
pyruvate dehydrogenase
step of the metabolism.
Here is a shorthand
representation
of glycogen. As you know
glycogen is a polymer formed
of glucose monomers.
Here is a cyclic
form of glucose,
and in glycogen we have
these one four linkages as
shown here.
Occasionally we'll
have one six linkages,
as in the case for branches.
But for simplicity we're not
going to represent them here.
Now we want to figure
out which one of these
carbons in glycogen--
we can label them
starting from here.
One, two, three,
four, five, and six.
Which one of these
carbons is going
to be lost as CO2 in the
pyruvate dehydrogenase step.
Now let's take a look at
the pyruvate dehydrogenase
reaction.
As you remember, one of
the endings of glycolysis
is the pyruvate
dehydrogenase reaction,
in which pyruvate loses a
CO2 molecule and forms acetyl
CoA which later can
enter the TCA cycle.
Now this carbon in the
carboxyl or group of pyruvate--
I'm going to label
with a red dot.
This is the carbon that
is being lost as CO2.
So we want to find out which
of the carbons in our glycogen
molecule ends up being this
red dotted carbon that's
being lost as CO2.
To figure this out we have
to backtrack from pyruvate
all the way to the
beginning of glycolysis
to figure out where this
carbon is coming from.
Shown here is a layout of the
entire glycolysis pathways
starting from glycogen.
Let me walk you through it
very quickly.
Glycogen, shown here--
we've shown only a couple
of monomers attached to
the glycogen and protein.
It's going to get hydrolyzed
by glycogen-phosphorylase
to form glucose-1-phosphate,
which then mutates to glucose
6-phosphate shown here.
And then becomes
fructose-6-phosphate,
fructose 1,6-bisphosphate.
Then the aldolase
reaction splits it
into dihydroxyacetone-phosphate
and glycerol-dihy-3phosphate,
or GAP.
Then the gap
dehydrogenase converts it
to 1,3-bisphosphoglycerate.
And then it would go
down, 3-phosphoglycerate,
2-phosphoglycerate,
phosphopyruvate, and finally,
pyruvate.
And here, I've also written
the pyruvate dehydrogenase
reaction.
Pyruvate becomes acetyl-CoA
by losing the CO2.
Once again, this carbon
that's lost, the CO2,
is the carbon that
we want to track.
So we're going to
put a red dot on it.
And as we just said, this
carbon is the carboxyl group
in the pyruvate.
So the way to solve this
problem is basically go backward
through the pathway
and figure out
where this carbon is coming
from in the original glycogen
molecule.
For these couple of
steps, it's pretty clear.
It's going to be the carboxyl in
each one of these molecules all
the way to
1,3-bisphosphoglycerate right
there.
So now this
1,3-bisphosphoglycerate is
coming from GAP.
So this carbon is, in fact,
the aldehyde carbon in GAP.
Now, as you guys know, trios
isomerase interconverts
between dihydroxyacetone
phosphate and GAP.
So this carbon in
dihydroxyacetone phosphate
is actually this carbon.
Because the phosphate group
is going to stay unchanged,
and then the
carbonyl group at C2
can interconvert with C1
to form an aldehyde here.
So any of these two carbons,
if they were labeled,
they would end up
being lost as CO2
in the pyruvate
dehydrogenase step.
Now, if we go backwards
in the aldolase reaction,
GAP and DHAP, when put
together, these carbons
are going to be carbons 3 and 4.
So counting here, 1, 2, 3.
This is a carbon that comes
from dihyrdoxyacetone phosphate.
And this is the
carbon that comes
from GAP, so carbons 3 and 4.
And obviously, they're going
to be staying carbons 3
and 4 all the way back to
glucose, 1, 2, 3, and 4
right there.
And also in glucose,
1 phosphate,
and consequently in
glycogen as well.
So to answer part
one, we can now
write here that carbons
3 and 4 of glycogen
are going to be lost at
the pyruvate dehydrogenase
step as carbon dioxide.
Part B of the problem deals
with the metabolism of glycerol.
As you know, glycerol is
formed by the hydrolysis
of triacylglycerides.
Now, we are asked
to trace a label
from the C2 carbon of
glycerol all the way
to the first step, in
which this carbon is last
as carbon dioxide.
Let's first take a look at
the metabolism of glycerol.
As I've shown here,
triacylglycerides
can be hydrolyzed
to form glycerol,
which is 1, 2, 3 propane triol.
Now, as you know, glycerol
is metabolized in two steps.
First, we have a
glycerol kinase that's
going to form a glycerol
3-phosphate, as shown here.
And then, we're going to
use a dehydrogenase that
uses NAD to oxidize the
second carbon of glycerol
to dihydroxyacetone phosphate.
Then it can enter glycolysis
very conveniently right here.
And then it's going
to continue getting
metabolized towards
pyruvate and acetyl-CoA,
as we've seen before.
Now, the second carbon in
glycerol is C2 right here.
I'm going to mark it
with a blue square.
So this carbon is
right here, and it's
going to end up right there.
Now, this second carbon in
dihydroxyacetone phosphate
is going to be the
second carbon in GAP
and then second carbon
here, here, here.
Isn't this fun?
Then the second
carbon in pyruvate.
Now, once the pyruvate
decarboxylates,
then it's going to be the
carbonyl of acetyl-CoA.
It's this carbon right here.
Now, so far, this carbon has
followed the metabolic pathway,
but it has not left yet as CO2.
Now, what happens to acetyl-CoA?
It's going to enter
the TCA cycle.
Now let's take a look
at the TCA cycle.
As we just said,
we're looking now
at the carbon, the first
carbon in acetyl-CoA
here, the carbon that has
the carbonyl group on.
So as I've shown here
in the to TCA cycle,
the two carbons in acetyl-CoA
are marked with this red line.
And they will enter and
combine as oxaloacetate
to form citrate.
Then citrate isomerizes
to isocitrate.
Then we're going to lose
a CO2 molecule, which
is this middle guy, to
form alpha-ketoglutarate.
But notice, the two
carbons from acetyl-CoA
are still in the molecule.
Then we're going to lose
another CO2 with this bottom one
to form succinyl-CoA.
But once again, the two carbons
that came from acetyl-CoA
are still here.
So in the first TCA
cycle, none of these CO2
will contain the label that
came from the glycerol.
Now, as we go through
the TCA cycle,
we reach this step
where it's succinate.
Now here, I stopped
putting this red mark,
because succinate is
a symmetric molecule.
So therefore, if
these two carbons
were coming from acetyl-CoA, at
this point they will scramble.
So we won't be able to
tell whether it's these two
carbons or these two carbons.
Now, let me backtrack
and put in the labels.
So acetyl-CoA, we
have this carbon
came from the C2 of glycerol.
So we'll find it in this carbon,
this carbon, this carbon,
this carbon.
Now, we get to the
succinate step,
and we said, well, it was here.
This would be the carbon that
corresponds to succinyl-CoA.
But because this
molecule's symmetric,
by the time we get
to the malate step
to add this hydroxyl group,
it's going to be to the carbon
next to the label or the
carbon further from the label.
Now, because the molecule
is symmetric, we can't--
the fumarase enzyme cannot
tell which carbon was labeled
and which wasn't.
Therefore, malate
is going to be--
half of the molecules
is going to have
the label on this
carbon, and half
is going to have the
label on this carbon.
So I'm going to write like
1/2 square and 1/2 square.
Similarly, when we
get to oxaloacetate,
the label is distributed
1/2 on one carboxyl group,
and the other 1/2 is going to
be on the other carboxyl group.
So we've gone through
the TCA cycle once,
and we have not lost the carbon
that came from the glycerol.
But look what happens
when we continue the TCA
cycle a second time.
So now let's say we combine
with an acetyl-CoA that
doesn't have any label at all.
Now, these two
carboxyl groups are
going to be these two
carboxyl groups in citrate.
And as we discussed,
both of these two groups
are going to be lost as
CO2 in these two steps.
First is the middle carboxyl
group that's being lost here.
And this other
carboxyl is going to be
lost at the alpha-ketoglutarate
dehydrogenase step.
So the second time we go
through the TCA cycle,
we lose half of the label at the
isocitrate dehydrogenase step
and half of the label at
the alpha-ketoglutarate
dehydrogenase step.
So I'm going to circle these.
So to answer part B, the
C2 carbon of glycerol
is going to be lost as
CO2 in the TCA cycle.
But we have to go once through
the cycle first, through which
none of the label will be lost.
And then the second
time, first in
the isocitrate
dehydrogenase, then
at the alpha-ketoglutarate
dehydrogenase,
we're going to be
losing the CO2 that came
from the C2 carbon of glycerol.
As you might imagine,
glycerol can also
be used to produce energy.
In fact, some bacteria
can grow on glycerol
using no other carbon source.
Now, in part C of
the problem, we're
going to explore how
much energy we can get
from one molecule of glycerol.
Let's first review the
metabolism of glycerol.
As we just discussed,
glycerol enters metabolism
with glycerol kinase,
which then in two steps
becomes dihydroxyacetone
phosphate, which
can enter glycolysis
all the way to pyruvate,
and then acetyl-CoA.
Here, the pyruvate dehydrogenase
allows us to lose one CO2,
and then acetyl-CoA
will enter the TCA
cycle, where within
one cycle, we're
going to lose two more CO2s.
So that's a total of three
carbons that we lose.
And that's exactly
how many carbons
we have in the glycerol.
Now, what we need to
keep track in order
to evaluate how
much energy we get
from one molecule of glycerol
is, whenever we need to,
use ATP.
For example, we need
to put in energy,
or whenever we generate
NADH or FADH2 molecules,
then we can then take to
the electron transport chain
and generate ATPs out of them.
So I've put together a list
of the steps in the pathway
where the energy
balance is affected,
either we need to use energy
or we are generating energy
in the form or ATP or in
the form of redox cofactors,
such as NAD and FAD.
So the first step,
glycerol kinase,
we're going to need to
spend one molecule of ATP.
So I'm going to put a minus
1 here for ATP equivalents.
Now, in the glycerol
3-phosphate dehydrogenase step,
which is shown right
here, we are generating
one molecule of NADH.
So plus 1 NADH.
Now, for the purpose
of this problem,
we're going to use the
convention the 1 NADH is
worth about 3 ATP equivalents.
Now, later on in
the pathway, we're
going to get to the GAPDH step
where we generate one more NADH
molecule.
So GAPDH, another NADH molecule.
That's equivalent to 3 ATPs.
So moving ahead, we have the
phosphoglycerate kinase step,
where we generate
1 ATP, and then we
have the pyruvate kinase step
where we generate 1 more ATP.
I have these written here.
So plus 1 ATP, and plus 1 ATP.
Now, finally, we know
that pyruvate, it's
going to be decarboxylated by
the pyruvate dehydrogenase,
and here, too, we're
generating 1 NADH.
So plus 1 NADH, that's going
to be equivalent to 3 ATPs.
And finally, the TCA cycle.
Now, we have one
molecule of acetyl-CoA
that enters the TCA cycle.
As you guys know for every
molecule of acetyl-CoA that
enters the TCA
cycle, we're going
to be generating 1, 2, 3 NADHs.
1 FADH2, and 1 GTP.
So the tally is 3 NADH,
1 FADH2, and 1 GDP.
Now, GDP is
equivalent to an ATP.
FADH2 counts as 2 ATPs,
and NADH counts as 3 ATPs.
So that's a grand
total of 12 ATPs.
So putting all of
this together from one
molecule of glycerol, when
fully metabolized to CO2,
we get 22 ATP equivalents.
So that's the final
answer for part
C. From one molecule
of glycerol,
we get about 22 ATP equivalents.
In part D of the problem,
we're tracing the same labels
we had in part A, but instead
of tracing them to CO2,
we're going to trace them
to the amino acid alanine.
As you know, one way
to produce alanine
is by transamination
from pyruvate.
Since we already tracked
the label to pyrate,
we need to know how do we
convert pyruvate into alanine.
Let's take a look
at that reaction.
As you know, alpha-keto
acids, such as pyruvate,
can be converted
into amino acids
by a transamination reaction.
Here, we're going to
use another amino acid
to donate the amino group to
the alpha-keto acid pyruvate
to form alanine.
Now, all these
transamination reactions
are catalyzed by PLP or
pyridoxal 5-phosphate, which
is a cofactor derived
from vitamin B6.
So when it's left to right,
in this transformation
is the other pair
of amino acid--
alpha-keto acid.
So basically, where is this
amino group coming from?
Typically for most
transaminases the other pair
is glutamate
alpha-ketoglutarate.
So I'm going to have
glutamate is going
to donate the amino group,
and in the process is
going to become an alpha-keto
acid alpha-ketoglutarate.
So in this way, pyruvate
becomes alanine.
Now, we were tracking the label
from this carbon, so the carbon
that will be lost as CO2 in
the pyruvate dehydrogenase
reaction.
So that is this carbon
right here in pyruvate.
So in the
transamination reaction,
this carbon becomes the
carboxyl carbon of alanine.
So if you were to start
with a glycogen that
was labeled at the 3 or 4--
the carbons 3 and
4, that label would
be lost as CO2 in the pyruvate
dehydrogenase reaction
that we saw in part A.
But also, that label
would be incorporated in
alanine at the carboxyl group
of this amino acid.
Parts E and F of
the problem deal
with tracing labels to the amino
acids glutamate and aspartate.
Now, both of these
amino acids have
their corresponding alpha-keto
acids as part of the TCA cycle.
So let's first take a
look at this TCA cycle.
Here, we have the
TCA cycle where
I highlighted
alpha-ketoglutarate going
into glutamate through a
transamination reaction.
Alpha-ketoglutarate
and alpha-keto acid
can undergo a PLP-catalyzed
transamination
to form glutamate.
And similarly, oxaloacetate,
another alpha-keto acid
can transaminate
to form aspartate.
Now, in part B of
the problem, we
were looking at
the label present
at carbon 1 in acetyl-CoA.
And we said that
this label will stay
inside the intermediates of the
TCA cycle for the whole round.
Now, when this label gets
the alpha-ketoglutarate,
it's going to be on
this carboxyl group.
So in the
transamination reaction,
the label is going
to end completely
on the furthermost
carboxyl in glutamate.
So that takes care of part E.
Now, if we continue
chasing this label,
once we get to the succinate,
the label is going to split
half and half between
these two carboxyl groups,
because we cannot
tell which one--
because the molecule is
going to be symmetric.
Similarly, for fumarate
and in malate as well.
So in oxaloacetate,
the label is going
to be on both of
the carboxyl group.
Half of the molecules
will have it one.
will have it on the other.
So therefore, the
aspartate is going
to mirror that label
distribution, 1/2 label on one
carboxyl, 1/2 label
on the other carboxyl.
So that should answer the
final part of this problem.
Now, I hope this
problem gave you
a better understanding of
what it means to chase labels
through biochemical pathways,
and also that chasing labels
can help us better
understand the mechanisms
of biochemical transformations.